- Ahh nooo!
- Oh no no no no no.
- No. No. No. I quit.
- I love this.
(jazzy music)
- No, oh no.
- Oh, cool.
Oh, it's just a blackhead extraction.
Right?
Unless there's a worm coming out of him.
- Oh man, I live for this.
- There's like pus coming out.
Oh, no.
- Ugh.
(laughs)
Oh no.
- Oh my god.
- You don't like this?
- I have goosebumps all over my body.
- Does this not gross you out?
Are you just fascinated?
- Uh, I'm pretty grossed out.
- But I can't look away.
- I can look away.
- It is like weirdly
satisfying in like a weird way.
A really gross way. Ugh.
(both exclaim)
- What is that?!
(both groan)
- Oh (bleep)!
- What part of this body is that?
- Probably his butt.
- No, no, no! (retching sound)
Oh my god.
- What is that? I don't wanna..
- Cheese, right?
It's cheese.
- [Voiceover] It looks
like a little vagina.
- Isn't this going against
Instagram's guidelines?
- Oh, (bleep)!
(screams)
- No, no I'm not even watching.
- [Voiceover] Oh my, it's so much.
- But it must feel amazing.
- Oh it's big. It's big.
Yeah get in.
Alright, alright. Come on. Ugh.
- Oh that's (bleep).
- Okay, let's play a game real quick.
How much pus do you
think there's gonna be?
Like, a decent amount, a
whole bunch, or just a little?
- I'm going to go with a whole bunch.
- Why do...
- Oh my!
- [Both] Eww!
- God!
How could that all be in there?
- What?
- What is it? Just frosting?
- [Both] Ahhh!
- Oh it's attached to real parts!
- Oh!
- Well, here's what I learned.
I only like watching blackheads
come out of people's noses.
I feel queasy.
- I feel sad.
- I'm not gonna go home,
and like to relieve stress,
instead of like, lighting a
candle and playing some music.
- There's kickball, there's work...
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- I guess my question is like,
is it a sadistic pleasure?
Is it an interest in the human body?
Is it, like...
what is it that interests you about this?
- It's probably just, it's like
a weird, cathartic feeling,
like watching something being fixed.
- I do wonder when I see stuff like this,
like, what would the founding
fathers think of this?
- That was my first thought.
I was like,
"Thomas Jefferson, what
do you think about this?"
- He'd probably be into it.